ça va bonjour alors je le disais
quelques tensions d'un cortège que s'est
il passé est ce que le calme est revenu
le calme est revenu sur cette place de
la bastille ce qui s'est passé c'était
un peu prévisible c'est que les
manifestants qui sont menacés en quelque
sorte par les forces de l'ordre puisque
tout au long de cette marche depuis la
place de la république jusqu'à la place
de la bastille les forces de l'ordre ont
encadré véritablement cette
manifestation en étant très proche des
manifestants je vous parlais tout à
l'heure de tension en tête du cortège
puisque certains manifestants voulaient
continuer à avancer été stoppé par les
gendarmes mobiles en l'occurrence et
puis lorsqu'on est arrivés sur cette
place de la bastille et bien il ya eu
des tensions à nouveau puisque des
manifestants ont tenté enfin de sortir
de ce dispositif policier et de gendarme
et à ce moment là il ya eu des tensions
avec des jets de projectiles et surtout
du gaz lacrymogène qui a été utilisé à
de nombreuses reprises par les forces de
l'ordre il ya vu un épais nuage de fumée
blanche sur cette place de la bastille
vous le voyez maintenant sur ces images
le calme est revenu ici mais c'est vrai
qu'il ya eu donc quelques tensions et
depuis ce moment là on est dans un calme
relatif puisqu'il ya toujours tous les
manifestants qui sont sur cette place
dans une ambiance plus plaisir que
lorsque nous sommes arrivés mais il ya
encore tout évidemment les forces de
l'ordre qui sont autour de cette place
et à chaque incursion notamment de la
brave évidemment il ya des tensions avec
des face à face un peu tendu parfois
entre des groupes de manifestants et les
forces de l'ordre alors cette
manifestation vous l'avez dit elle est à
l'origine notamment pour le personnel
hospitalier qui réclament plus de moyens
cela fait des mois voire même des années
parfois qu'ils réclament cela et puis
n'ont pas été convaincus en tout cas une
partie d'entre eux n'a pas été convaincu
par les annonces faites lors des accords
du ségur de la santé signée hier il
explique que déjà tous les syndicats
n'ont pas signé ces accords et puis
qu'il ya aussi une forme de déconnexion
entre la tête des syndicats et puis la
base qui elles réclament davantage de
moyens je propose d'écouter ces
témoignages c'est un des membres du
personnel hospitalier qui sont venus
spécialement de normandie aujourd'hui à
paris pour cette manifestation un cirage
de pompes passe et on va embellir la
chose on veut
comment nous faire croire plein de
choses et puis que derrière on rigole un
petit peu on fait des pieds de nez aux
to the speed aujean hospitalier enfin
les personnels hospitaliers pardon donc
là on doit d'une petite chose pour
calmer le jeu mais quand tout sera fini
et ben on va continuer le processus et
on fermera les les oreilles de des
demandes de tous les gens personnel
hospitalier donc voilà on est là pour ça
et que en fin de compte qu'on arrête bas
tout simplement nous prendre pour des
blaireaux et puis le cortège est
également composé de nombreux gilet
jaune les mobilisations des jeux les
jaunards peu faibli ces dernières
semaines mal couverts des manifestations
le gilet jaune qui n'avait pas rassemblé
beaucoup de personnes il semble que
d'une forme de regain puisque dans cette
manifestation aujourd'hui beaucoup de
gilet jaune présent et déjà les jeunes
originaires de plusieurs endroits de
france de bordeaux ou encore de la
région centre ils sont venus à paris
pour cette date symbolique du 14 juillet
ce date de la révolution française
d'ailleurs des slogans révolution sont
scandés assez régulièrement ici on est à
la place de la bastille c'est évidemment
là aussi très symbolique je propose
d'écouter un gilet jaune en tout cas il
me seront mandic plus comme gilet jaune
mais c'est un ancien gilet jaune
originaire de bordeaux c'était au micro
de cynthia lauvergeon alors on a
toujours appelé à l' converger avec avec
le personnel hospitalier
d'ailleurs nous aujourd'hui on n'est
plus chez les jeunes on est citoyen en
colère
voilà parce que ça représente toutes les
luttes et aujourd'hui c'est important de
toutes les luttes convergent ensemble je
prends par exemple les les patrons de
boîte de nuit
on aurait aimé aujourd'hui que les
patrons de bars de nuit soit avec nous
dans la rue tous ensemble et je pense
que la grande union des luttes il faut
qu'elle se fasse maintenant c'est
important on attend la rentrée j'espère
que les gens le reste des gens vont se
réveiller parce que malheureusement
c'est toujours les mêmes qu'on a collé
dans la rue et fo faut réveiller les
autres que ce soit il ya tellement de
trucs qui vont pas à l'heure de genre
ducos bat pas je trouve pas ça normal
voilà pour ces revendications des gilet
jaune qui annonce d'autres actions
évidemment même si cette journée dé
marquer d'une pierre blanche depuis un
moment déjà à l'été dans le viseur d'un
certain nombre de manifestants qui
souhaitaient absolument continuer à
occuper le terrain on sait date
symbolique du 14 juillet alors même qu
emmanuel macron a reçu ce matin lors des
cérémonies qui est personnel soignant
ceux qui sont ici nous parle parfois
d'un geste plus symbolique qu'autre
chose
voilà donc que pour cette manifestation
qui est arrivée place de la bastille on
va désormais suivre l'évolution de la
situation avec je vous le répète
quelques tensions lorsque nous sommes
arrivés ici et les forces de l'ordre
toujours présentes en très grand nombre
pour encadrer cette manifestation
thomas merci pour toutes ces précisions